was it 57 was it challenged five
standard invite thanks for your patience
as usual slow going in the very
beginning there so game one of how many
I don't know ok might have 60 k e 60
night okay this is Wow when you call
this a 3 i've seen a three when it is
when the bishop has first played to beat
be for naught this so just preventing it
all together huh hmm you know i think
there is something off with that i'm
looking into maybe changing it into a
benoni structure because in a benoni
structure i don't think that a three
turns out to be purposeful so c5 in
other words
and what else
and I think even in this position that
a3 move is just turning out to not be so
good we'll see about that though I mean
like okay I don't have this check ever
available to me but what do I have nice
knight c6 is a follow-up i have d 5 in
and i don't know let's just get
developed let's see six why not
ok
um okay why just built my Center I could
be looking to maybe pinpoint this beep
on later on I'll be reluctant to play
Bishop c5 because before could be played
and then actually this is starting to
show itself as being useful I really
don't want to allow that now this this
has some of my thoughts but I think I
just want to make sure I'm one move away
at least be until I castle I want to be
just one move away now I'm going to give
this a bit more thought right here up to
be eight hitting this pawn or no yeah
i'm going to go with this to be a why
not
and if there's take I take towards the
center if there's a bishop check I just
play Bishop to d7 and want more
ok
let's see just castle its castle I don't
see any anything else to be doing maybe
there's going to be this Bishop to a 6
smooth but actually not so fast okay
just take like this towards the center
221 majority in the center now and I
guess I could be considering what ship
here Queen 85 queenie queenie five with
Bishop to e6 to follow my plan is to put
pressure on these ponds right here maybe
here isn't good or maybe it is yeah like
Paul yet it is i'm pretty sure now i am
uh actually i just had a flashback of
cambridge springs and how in one of my
last game analysis videos i was touching
on the clean when she comes out to a
five she's getting out of the pin
placing white in the pin and also
functioning laterally so this right here
is a possibility but not now I think if
i push there's just takes the queen is
defending the bishop and there's no
problems the other threat that I had is
that if white castle died could snip
this pond since it was having to watch
over both since this pound has happened
to watch over both the night and pond
right there ah Bishop e6 it seems like
it might be good yeah that's i'm pretty
sure that that is looking good although
is their tactic bishop here is Knight
takes pawn available whoa
oh hang out hang on for a second here I
don't know about that Bishop a six
Knight takes pawn Queen takes I'm on the
bishop let's try it I haven't run all
the calculations but I think at the end
of it even if white wins upon I think I
could still maybe get this pawn right
here that what that right there was a
case of me just being lazy I didn't want
to calculate is my opponent listening
are they going to take on d5 don't you
dare if you take on d5 that means you're
listening
okay all right we're not having that are
we will have to take a closer look at
that a little bit later now I could chop
here and then chop the night but um it
does i do a compromise my pawn structure
over here takes and then there's Bishop
takes Knight pawn takes and then a
recapture I could get here there's a
queen check I could sidestep it it's a
little bit scary but hmm well I better
start moving that's one thing and you
know I'm not going to run for that I
don't like the idea of compromising my
king side position I think just going
with something as calm as doubling on
the B file in pinpointing this guy is
going to be a good alternative and by
good i mean safe safer alternative i
think i could still end up winning upon
but not compromise my king size
structure notice the difference little
patience maybe is going to keep my king
safer and still maybe is going to
translate into the window some material
i do still need a flight square if i
ever play this move there's always just
Bishop takes here first actually maybe i
should consider right now let's see boom
now I don't want to let's throw that in
there and what were we going to do next
I guess queen bee 6 Bishop takes Knight
I think that's the end of the game you
can't allow this Bishop to put pressure
on this pond it's already going to be
difficult enough to defend be too with
just the rooks so I'm going to play here
there is a possibilities for forks like
as soon as I take here there's a fork
but I think I still went out because I
could just take the rook first both
under a minute so now what hmm okay
White is running backwards here and
hmm
to offer a queen exchange
I'm gonna recapture with oh okay there
they're really guarding that now come
over here 21 I still want to get at this
let's come over a little bit more and a
little bit more just to watch over this
oh I just dropped my rook oh man this is
not a good start Bishop takes rook Oh
was missed or even rook right there was
available we're both low on time well
what a terrible start no don't you dare
start out like this take that pond
that's a free pond take free stuff I'm
not taking the free stuff I'm going to
take it now we both have very little
time and now finally I could crash
through at this point enough gas on that
be to point whoa easy there night okay
wow that got luck that got really really
crazy right there ah unnecessary
unnecessary to get into that time
pressure like that alright let's let's
hit that back button and flip the screen
where is there an improvement right here
I don't know I think there's a big
difference between playing a three after
my bishop is played here first I'm
trying to show that it's a not going to
be purposeful so that's why I was
running with this c5 move and with this
i was referencing the Benoni but
yeah I don't know like what can you do I
mean really didn't turn into a banani if
pond push then I think this turns out to
be a waste I guess there I get some is
some purpose here it is stopping a pin
but something just seems off I think you
should really consider than either one
of your nights out right here entering
an Enzo so I don't know 83 has my
attention is that's what I'm getting at
that's the quick summary and I don't
know about building my center like this
maybe you could try just three first and
maybe there's something to be said for
Bishop g5 in the knee three not yet
giving my bishop essentially the
possibility of coming out to a six
because that's what you're doing there
you're doing two things you're building
my Center and allowing Bishop basic
stuff so that's another thing that has
my attention just I mean you did follow
up with Bishop to g5 just maybe do it
right away starting to feel pretty
comfortable as soon as the pawn
structure is set up like this I have a
lot of pressure on the queenside and
right here I think you could actually go
forward with Knight takes pawn Knight
takes pawn Queen takes Queen King takes
Queen Knight takes Knight Bishop takes
Bishop knight takes Bishop Bishop takes
Bishop and I think after all that lights
up upon actually I think I was going to
take it in a different direction after
Knight takes pawn I think I might have
done what might have I had done there oh
now that would have been good night
takes pawn Queen takes Knight
Queen takes Queen night now it's kind of
just panning out to be the same thing I
don't know I think this is I shouldn't
have been so lazy and this was an
opportunity for white tactics exchange
Queens this guy all of a sudden becomes
unprotected or there's the thought of
maybe grabbing him with check that's the
idea so lazy calculation but it was not
taking advantage of and this is very
difficult now cannot kick that Rick away
and be too sure enough ended up falling
but